[Music]
I'm Clarence where I'm from you fight to
survive I'm not a bad person just
playing the cards I was
dealt mom one day I'm going to get you
out of here I have a plan what are we
doing here Jesus lives there
[Music]
hallu I want to be like that in 10 years
I want to be like that
now I need to figure out what inspires
him I can just replicate what he does
imagine the money people will give us
hallelujah I getd you on to like I'm
your Uber oh Dead one open your
eyes what are you trying to prove and
I'm not a nobody you find fith and you
will find all the
answers hallu parents you are guilty of
the crime fraud for your own ill-gotten
games you give me Jesus of Nazareth I
will let you walk free and I will give
you power wealth you be
[Music]
somebody I die before I give him up the
ram then death it is my congregation
going to operate like a corporation I
want my flowers and flower bases I want
carnations I want B I want p and
flower
Hallelujah CL in spite of yourself ways
there's a beautiful soul in there
somewhere Hallelujah God Hallelujah
Hallelujah Hallelujah
Hallelujah Jesus of Nazareth I'm a God
so when you see me say
hallelujah I'm destined to be
here hallelujah come
on damn Hallelujah
baby